Hi,
today we are going to talk about how to
stop AI agent hallucinations
with five techniques beyond the prompt.
Each one is a code change, not a prompt
change.
Let's see.
Every time your AI agent responds, you
are paying for the words going in and
the words coming out.
And your bill, you will see those
calling tokens. Yeah.
And the more tokens you are sending, the
more you pay.
And if what you send is not quite right,
too much, or missing something
important, your AI agent start to
hallucinate.
There are five techniques
to help reduce tokens waste,
improve accuracy, and catch failure
before you submit them. And each one is
a code change,
not a prompt change at all.
So, let's see it.
First, we have semantic tool selection.
You filter which tool go into context on
every call. The model only see what it
needs for that specific query. Second,
we have graph rack.
For precise queries like aggregation,
counts, multi-hop reasoning,
and you replace the text retrieval with
a structured graph query.
The model gets a compute a verifiable
answer, not a sample
as rack do.
Three, multi-agent validation. A second
agent can check every response before it
reaches the users.
And four,
neuro-symbolic guardians,
you rule life in Python, not in the
prompt, and the model cannot escape
them.
So,
five, runtime guardians, because if you
don't want to block, you can steer, and
you don't you don't need to block
everything. And when a rule fires, the
agent self-correct and complete the
task.
No hard stop, no user advice. So, for
each technique, I will show you the
agent without it, and then with it, so
you can compare. And all the demos
uh I'm using a travel agent that I built
using a Strands agent.
And a Strands agent is a open-source
agent framework that we maintain on AWS.
And
I am Elizabeth Fuentes Leon. I am a
developer advocate for AWS. I'm focused
on agentic application.
And here, in this QR code, you will find
everything that you will need
to recreate all these techniques that
I'm going to show you in a moment.
So, let's get into
Let's get into it.
So,
semantic tool selection,
our travel agent has 29 tools.
Flights, hotels, payments, weather,
cancellations, all all our dummy tools
are not like a travel agent for real,
but
every time that user sends a message,
all the 29 tools description go into the
context windows.
The model reads all of them before
deciding what to do.
And if your agent has memory, the rows
to every conversation adds more context
that gets sent with every single
message.
And you pay for every single one of
those tokens,
whether the model ends up using the tool
or not.
To understand where those tokens come
from, you need to see what a tool
actually looks like to the model.
In a Strands, you write a function with
the
tool decorator
that's the tool,
and a name, a description, and a
docstring
typed parameters.
Then, Strands take that and generate a
schema with name, description,
parameters, and the schema is what goes
into the context windows on every call.
Each tool schema is about
17 or 200 tokens,
depending of how many parameters it has.
If our travel agent [snorts] has 29
tools, that adds up to somewhere around
3,000 tokens per call,
just for the tool description.
Before your message, before the
response,
every single call.
By creating a tool database,
we can filter the tools that the agent
may need before the agent the symbol.
With this filter, the model sees only
three most relevant tools.
Tokens usage drops from thousands to
fewer than 300.
Let me show you in the code.
Here in my cure ID, this is the Let me
clear all the outputs.
So, first we need to install the
requirements.
Here is the requirement file. This is a
Jupyter notebook because it's more
simple to show everything, but there is
one application that you can run if it
is more comfortable for you.
So, here are the requirements. I have
the A strands agent and because I'm
using open AI as a model invocation, I'm
using the API from open AI.
And
I need a strands agent for open AI.
You can use open AI strands agent with
all our my god, almost all the model
provider. And with a strand we Amazon
better of course because we as AWS, we
are the maintaining of this framework.
And to use a Amazon better, you don't
need to add
the model provider.
And
because I need to embed in I need to
create embeddings for my vector tools
database, I'm using the sentence
transformer. This is a super simple
model that runs locally, so it's free.
So, you want you can run this locally
you computer without expense another
model embedding.
And
you can use a strands with all llama
too. So, if you have a local model, you
can run everything
in this in your computer for free
without expense any tokens.
And
I use it files as my vector store,
local, super simple.
And well, right now I'm going to use a
Neo4j. This is for other
demo that I'm going to show you in a
moment. And because I'm using some
environments, I'm using Python of
And let's see. So here I want to run
this. Let me put it bigger. I know that
you have it some problems.
Bigger. Little more little less.
And here, this is better.
So.
I style my requirement. I already did
that. And I'm using OpenAI, so I need my
my API.
My API key. API key.
And here, I invoke my strands. I need
the agent because I want to be like
agent that I'm using OpenAI. And I have
a bunch of tool dummy tools here. I let
I going to show you in a moment. And I
want to use this because I have some
um
functions that I'm using to
uh create the build the index for my
vector store. And I need the search
tools when I'm using the vector store, I
put my query there. I search for the I
search for the tool that I'm going to
use using vector um
um search for vectors.
And I swap the tools. I going to show
you that in a moment. So let me show you
all my dummies tools. Where is the
engage register here.
Here I have all my tools. Uh this is for
swap. Search, build index. And where are
my tools? Shoo shoo shoo shoo shoo here.
So here are all the dummy tools I
created for this. You know, it's super.
This is a demo, please. It's not
something that you can use to go to
production. No, please.
And okay. So where is this this one? So
I run this.
And I build my semantic index. I already
did that via Yeah. So, I have 29 tools
here, 29 dummy tools, and I want to test
this with a lot of different queries,
and this is the ground truth. I have a
ground truth because I know what is the
best um
the best tool to answer the question, so
we can know if our agent is okay or not
okay. So, let's run this.
We have 90 queries and 29 tools. So,
this is some helper functions. I don't
care.
Yeah, I care, but I don't want to
explain you that. So, this is my agent,
my traditional agent, where I'm putting
all my 29 tools inside the agent.
I have my model, some helper function.
This is my agent. I only This is the way
I create a agent using a strange agent.
I put all my tools,
and my system prompt is you are a travel
assistant. You select correct tool to
answer question. Oh my god, super.
And the model.
Let's run this.
And this is whatever. This is some
function to count the tokens because in
inside this strange agent, you can you
can count the tokens. You You can know
how many tokens are using for in and out
the the agent.
This is some helper function, and yeah.
This is Every time that I put a
uh
a prompt inside this agent, I'm only
sending the prompt, and the agent
respond. Then, I I use a new agent
because it's a
a fork. So, I'm not having a
conversation with the agent. I only send
a uh
a question, and I receiving an answer.
So, for each question, it is spend
around 2,000 tokens.
So, in and not always it give me the
right answer.
Here. So, yes, I have um I'm not so good
at accuracy, and the average is 1
1,000
tokens. Now, let's use my new AI with
the semantic approach.
The thing The first thing that I do is
for every single query, for every single
prompt, I send the query to my search
tools, and I going to receive the top
two the top K three
most relevant
with more probability to response my
query because this is a semantic search
inside my vector store.
And
then I use that response. I going to
select that name, and I going to put
that tools inside my AI. So, I only
going to use the three tools that this
semantic search
retrieve me for my AI, and I send that
only tools. And this is my function
helper, and that's it.
So, I going to send the all the queries
again the same. And for the first
question, I have 4,000 tokens three blah
blah blah. And yeah, we have a huge
different because I don't send the all
the 29 to tools in all the queries.
So, yeah, bam bam.
And
okay, semantic memory. Yeah, okay, now
come on. Finish. So, let's let's let's
go to the next one. So, this engine is
only sending a question, and I receive a
response. I don't have any conversation
with this engine.
What happen if I start to have a
conversations? If the engine remember
me? So, we need to we need to send only
the tools that this engine is going to
use. Because if I give the all the tools
I'm using in the conversation history,
uh then I it's going to be in a moment
that I want to have the 29 tools inside
my engine. So, we are not resolving the
we are not having a a
um
We are not resolving our problems in the
engine when we having a conversation
with the engine.
So, we need to put the tools and then we
need to remove the tools.
And we can do that with the swap tools.
And let's run this. And what swap tools
I got run this, no. Let me Let me show
you first the swap tools
functions here the register.
I delete this
because with a strands
in each invocation, you have complete
control of the status because this is a
a gentle loop and you can
we use this a gentle loop
how for
because this is a gentle loop and you
can do
almost whatever you want. You can put
and remove everything inside the loop
with some few lines of code. So, let's
see.
Here we have the engine. We have the
tool register through your through tool
registers.
It's something inside the engine status.
So, we can clear the tools
and that's it. So, in the next
invocation, we can clear the all tools
and we can add the new tools.
Here, where is my I have a lot of things
here.
So, I run this.
It's going to take a moment.
>> And yes, we can see that in each
invocation, my amount of talking is
increasing.
Why I have more? Because I'm sending the
chat history as well. So, I send the
tools that I need, only the tools that I
need, and the chat history. So, that's
why I can see that my amount of token is
bigger and bigger.
And the see,
the accuracy is better. And yeah, we
have more tokens.
So, yes, probably we don't have the best
accuracy here because this is a super
demo with super dummies tools, and some
queries are ambiguous on purpose because
search for something, for something,
check something. And the demo has a
generic tools, dummy tools,
with some similar name.
And when all the 29 tools are visible,
the model sometimes pick the wrong one.
And with the filtering, those generic
tools uh only appears in the query
actually match them.
So, you can run everything and
you can test this. So, this is only that
run only locally. But, what happen when
you want to put this demo in production?
You can of course, you can build a
bigger, better store. I don't know, you
can use Postgres. I think it's too much.
But,
we on AWS, we have
Amazon Bedrock Agent Core.
So, Amazon Bedrock Agent Core is a
service dedicated only to agents in
production. And in size of Agent Core,
we have Agent Core Gateway. So, Agent
Core Gateway Gateway
allows you to build this index
[clears throat]
uh
alone. So, you only have to say, "Hey,
this is my tools." And Agent Core
Gateway is going to build everything for
you. And it can have the
vector search inside. So, the routing
layer is inside the Agent Core and it
handles the tool selection
automatically. So, you register your
tools once and it find the right one for
each request. It's the same principle
but without infrastructure to manage.
Now, let's see the next one.
GraphRAG.
You know,
RAG is retrieval augmented generation.
Is how agents access your own data.
You take the user question, search your
documents for the most similar content
using vector search and pass what you
find to the model.
The model answer from that, it's work
well for open question.
Find me something about this topic.
But there is a category of question
where that breaks down.
What is the average rating across all
hotels in Paris? How many hotels have a
pool?
Vector search always returns something
even when nothing is truly relevant. And
the agent only sees the top end chunks
of your all data at a time.
It cannot aggregate, count, or traverse
relationship across all the full data
set.
So, it estimates.
And it present that estimates as a real
fact, you know, a real answer.
So, here we have graph
you build a vector store and it
retrieves three chunks from 300
documents and the model guesses.
If we are using graph rack, you can run
a query across all the and returns a
compute results.
Graph address this differently
because instead of a retrieving text
chunk, you can build a knowledge graph
from the documents. Knows relationship
and structured data.
For the demo, I'm going to use Neo4j
locally and the model is going to write
a Cypher query to search it.
Cypher query is Neo4j query language.
It's similar to SQL. So, the graph run
that query across all the data. And the
model gets back a compute verified
results,
not a sample.
And before running this demo, I'm going
to start the dependents. Let me show
you. Let me Let's go to the code.
So, graph
This is the notebook I'm going to share
with you. So, we need to install the
requirements again.
What we have here, let me see.
This is the first one, yeah.
Requirements.
I have I'm going to use OpenAI again.
Let me just close this. I'm going to use
Neo4j and we need Neo4j for graph rack.
And for the
engine that is using normal rack, we are
going to be a super simple
uh vector store in files and we are
going to use again the sentence
transformer.
And let's see. I already have all right,
I invoke [clears throat] my open AI.
This is my tools. I I because I want to
create some tools here, I want to use
open AI and I use in graph database.
And this is my I have my Neo4j locally.
And let's run this.
And this is something to check Neo4j.
So, I'm building my
uh vector store. This is my files and
this is my Neo4j that I have here
locally. I don't know if I can show you.
I think not.
And I have a tool, a normal tool created
with a decorator. This is to search
inside the
my vector store. You see that's super I
I have the query. I I create I I create
the the embedding for my query and then
I search inside the vector store and I
have the query for the knowledge graph.
So,
here the model
need to understand that to search in the
query in the graph knowledge base, it
need to build a Cypher query. So, I put
that in the context because we already
know how to build uh tools, right?
I put that in the context. I have my
driver to send the data to uh to connect
with the vector store and to send the
Cypher query that the model is going to
create for me. And this is to read the
results and that's it. That's the only
tool that I need to search in my
knowledge graph.
Okay, this is my model
open AI. This is my rag.
My rag engine and uh this is my graph
engine. I have two different engine to
compare the results.
Let's see.
Well, I have a problem. Yeah, I'm ready.
So, let's do this round the first test.
Aggregation.
Here, what is the question?
What is the average guest rating across
all hotels in Paris?
So, meanwhile this engine is Oh, it's
already done. So, what I have here
I have the average guest rating across
the hotels listed in Paris is
Um it calculate, you know.
When something When I'm using rag, it go
to the to the vector store, it receive
the n uh possible answers for this
question. Because this is an
aggregation,
it's going to use the data that it
receive to build a mathematical
uh operation. This is the thing that I
have here. So, everything that we see
here is the is the model reasoning.
So, when I run
the graph engine on the mean,
the engine is only going to give me the
answer, you know, only these tokens
here.
Because the Cypher query, it can give me
the mathematical operation itself. It
can do that. So, we don't need the
engines, the LLMs, the model uh do that
for me because the Cypher query already
give me the right question. So, it is 47
and the average. So, here in this uh
first we are lucky
because probably they are Yeah, only two
hotels. But, what happened if this
vector store have
more than two or three hotels in the in
the vector store? So, we are not going
to give a real answer. It's going to the
LLM is going to calculate with the only
three answer that it receive. So, it's
going to build this operation with only
three hotels.
But, if the vector store have more than
three,
we are going to have some problems.
Something that I am you know uh
yeah.
So, let's run the next one. The prices
counting.
Something similar too. How many hotel
have a swimming pools as a amenity?
How many again? So, it give me the the
traditional
It's appear that the search did not
return some specific information about
hotels in Paris. Okay. What happened
with the other one?
There are currently no hotel that offer
swimming pools.
No I. There is no hotels. So, the other
one is like mm
would you like to ask about hotel with
other specific amenity or information?
It's like mm maybe it is or maybe I
don't know.
Yeah, it's not so accurate, okay?
So, mostly conversation.
Oh, what is my question?
What are the room types and price for
the highest rating hotels?
What are the rooms types and price? This
two question.
So,
it search the fact I had had only one.
The highly rated hotels in any company
Paris blah blah blah. I I don't speak
French.
With the guest rating is that one.
However, I currently don't have Okay,
blah blah blah. A lot of data there.
So,
what happened with the other one?
Receiving notification for Oh, I have a
error.
I hear in the second one I receive the
the question. The highly rated hotel is
harmony blah blah blah. They offer
following types. But, unfortunately
these rooms are not available.
So, I receiving a
answer. I don't receive a lot of blah
blah blah there. I only receive the
answer what I need.
And for the next one, how was the
meditation?
What is the question? Tell me about
hotels in Antarctica. A spoiler, there
is no hotel in Antarctica. There is zero
hotels in Antarctica and let's see.
It's appear that the certain order to
specific information about hotel Okay,
because they are I search for the other
have the tail blah blah blah in the
If you are looking for particular that
experience specifically inquire about
visiting Antarctica.
No.
Please let me know and I can assist you
for it. Okay, a lot of tokens that I
spending there in that answer for Elena.
What happened with the other one? They
are currently no hotel listed in
Antarctica. Of course, because it create
a cyber query, the cyber query and it
receive zero.
So,
it no, it give me a honest answer.
Here's summary that close grade for me
for this Neo4j notebook. But here is
something that I want to show you before
go to the other one.
So,
here something that I love for Neo4j
because why I'm using Neo4j? Because in
the library
the Neo4j give me
uh it can build
it use a LLM. I'm using the OpenAI as
well to build the knowledge graph. So,
how I build my knowledge graph? I only
have a bunch of data, a bunch of txt
only text and I send that data to the
Neo4j library that I miss out.
Okay, I send that data to this
and Neo4j using this all this um library
just right here, it can understand all
my data and it can build the graph for
me. So, I don't need to create that
using the simple knowledge graph
pipeline inside the knowledge graph
library. So, that's why I'm using Neo4j.
It's amazing. It's super simple to use.
So, I invite you to use it at that. So,
let's go to the next one.
So, multi-agent validation.
Sometimes an agent fails, and nobody
find out.
It calls a tool, and the tool returns an
error, and the agent does not surface
that error.
It generate a confidence success
response instead.
The user thinks it work. You think it
work. It didn't not. The agent acts and
validate its own output in the same
loop.
There's no separation, no second
opinion. So, when something goes wrong,
it rationalizes and tells you it's okay.
It work.
Here is what happens. Inside a single
agent, when it fail, it calls the tool,
gets an error, rationalizes
it, and returns a success response.
The user never sees the error.
You can address this by adding a
validation layer. You can have three
agents in sequence.
One acts, one checks, and other approve
or rejects.
Strands agent has a built-in class for
this called swarm.
It manage the handoff between agents
automatically.
You just
the role of each agent in a system
prompt.
And let me show you that.
So, this demo only needs a Swarms agent
with open AI integration. Let's see the
requirements here.
All you need of is Swarms agent. We
don't need anything more.
Let's go to the notebook here.
And
the key important thing here is the
already running is Let me see here. Is
the Swarm.
The Swarm it's what lets you to connect
multiple agents together
without creating like a for a while
manually to put the all these agents
together. It can build a chain and
manage the handoff between them
automatically.
So, here we are going to create three
agents.
Let me go down because we have the
normal and we have some ground truth
data.
So, here is to create a a single agent.
So, we have we are going to test three
different scenarios to validate a
booking. This They we expect true to
enable hotels. We expect false and
non-existing hotels and missing booking.
We expect false, too. This is how we
created single agent. We need a prompt,
some tools.
And we are using the tools that we have
here.
And here we know that this is the data.
So, the agents can can give out the
answer that we are looking for.
And that's it. Let me go to the other
ones. Oh, wait here.
So, how we build the Swarm?
I already run this. I want to show you
this one. So, we are going to build
three different agents. The executor,
the validator and the critic.
The
we have a system prompt. You are
executor agent for a hotel booking
system.
>> [clears throat]
>> Use the provide tools to fulfill
requests accurately and blah blah blah.
The validator is you are a validator
agent. Review what the executor did and
output exactly on off.
And we have the critics that is going to
set here approve or no reject.
Let's run this.
And oh, what is here? Our model didn't
define the model. Sorry.
Sorry, please. Forgive me the life
because I didn't run this one.
Let's run now because this is the
the normal.
And the model is there, right? What?
A little bias. Run that.
What's happening with you? Let me go
this. Let me copy and paste.
This one.
I don't know why this give me problem.
Multi-agent swarm is the time the same
name. Come on.
Yeah, you can see this is life. I don't
going to edit this.
So, yes.
Okay, we have
Thank you. And the swarm, how we how we
create the swarm? We have swarm and
the swarm function, we put all the
agents together and the entry point is
the executor. So, all everything is
going to start in the executor and then
it's going to hand off.
And six time because you can handle
that, too. So, get the swarm final
response. Let's do a for and they send
all the response.
And book the Grand Hotel.
I have booked a Grand Hotel for Alice
tonight. Booking blah blah blah. Hand
off.
Valid. Okay.
Looks good.
Critic, approve.
So, the critics is approving the this.
This is the other one.
And we can run some comparison here if
you want.
So, here we can see that the swarm
handles the flow between the between all
the uh three different saying. It was
what happens when the single agent tries
to conflict something that does not
exist in the system.
And now the same request through the
swarm, the executor gets the error, the
validator catches, the critic rejects
this, and the user never see a
fabricator response.
So, you can we can test here with the
single agent that it's a suggested
unknown entry and return success.
And the swarm, it have a executor that
go the error, validate saying, "Hey,
come on, man. Hallucination and the
critic they reject." So, the user sees a
clear failure.
The fabricator confirmation so missing
the issue here.
And you can run this to compare the two
different agents. So, here we can see
that the single agent it have everything
like a yeah, it's okay, it's correct.
But in the multi-agent swarm, you can
see that the last one is a you know,
missing issue here. Something is
happening.
Now, let's go to the next one.
Okay. Neuro-symbolic Guardians.
You have a rule for your agent. Let's uh
say maximum 10 guesses per reservation.
You write in in the system prompt.
You even write in in the tool
description. And the agent still calls
the tool with 15. No, because it is
ignoring you.
Because prompts probably are
suggestions, not constraints.
The model process them as a text.
Not as a logic it has to execute.
It's probabilistic.
Only code execute logic.
A rule in the prompt the model read it
as a suggestion.
A rule in the code the model can not
escape it.
Neuro-symbolic guardians rules put the
rules in the code. E-strands A and has a
few that call him hooks.
The the function that is trans called
automatically at specific moments in the
A and loop.
It is this case right before a tool
executes. So you have a hook.
You write the rule, check the parameters
and if they fails you cancel the call.
Let me show you this in the code.
Here we have the Jupiter notebook.
We have the requirements here.
Um what is the same requirements as the
previous demos we only need I will
install everything again.
We only need E-strands and open AI. We
don't need anything else.
And um my
API.
And here is the thing important.
In this demo
are these three hooks provided in this
trans base class. So you
allows you to create the hook. So we
have hook provider, hook register and
before to call event.
And the tool register is what E-strands
pass
you to register your call back. And
before to call event is the event that
fires every time the model is about to
execute shadow.
That last
one is what makes it possible the
intercept the call before it runs. So,
you have the before two calls even and
call we have after two calls even that
we are not going to use that here.
And
let's see the rule in the prompt.
Remember, the model reads as a text and
it may follow
or not follow them. So, let's see this.
I want to run this.
So, here we have some similar state
that we are going to use in this engine.
And
let me this is the symbolic rule.
So, booking rule if if rule booking rule
as a this is something that
we create. Let me show you the rules
here. So, we have
the rules.
Rule one.
Validate dates. Check in must be before
check out. If what is validated they
check out.
This is something that it check. This is
a something that is going to invoke when
the rule is
is uh
is must have to use it.
And
uh to do
We have another rule for max guesses.
Maximum take guesses per booking. So, if
I want to use I don't know I if I want
to book in uh
uh
I want to do a booking for 11, it's
going to block me. It's not going to
reject the booking.
And we have some confirmation rule.
Payment before confirm. You know, you
can confirm if you don't have the
payment. Cancellation rule.
Cancellation within the cannot cancel
within 48 hours of check in. So, this is
something that I've created here, you
know, to this demo.
So, I have booking rules and I have
confirmation rules. I don't I use in
here the cancellation rule.
So,
create validation hook.
We create the validation hooks here,
right?
Like this, neuro-symbolic rule, and we
use the hook provider.
So, we have a bunch of code here.
Then, we add the booking rules, the
confirmation rules, and the state.
And you can check this by yourself
later, but we want to see the demo
running. So, that we define the claim
tools that we are going to use them for
the booking hotels and the process
payment.
This is the the normal tools, you know,
and we need to add that tools to the
hooks. I think I add that.
Yeah. Tool name, book hotel. So, this
thing is going to get the eight when the
book hotel is using the
Yeah, the book hotel.
Okay?
So, let's create the agents for the
comparison. So, we are going as the
other demos, we have three different
scenarios. Confirm booking without
payment. Payment must be verified before
the confirmation. This is the rule that
I must trigger this.
We have booking hotel exceeding guest
limit, and we have valid booking for
five guests.
So, yeah, we have the three scenarios.
And we have the normal engine, the
normal engine, and the vaseline engine.
And we have the engine with the neuro
the neuro-symbolic guardians. So, we
have the hook, the neuro-symbolic hook.
Uh this is the same. Here, yeah.
And
we add this
If you can see, the normal engine
[snorts] is only three lines. The tools,
the model, and this is the line that
give us the difference between these two
engines. So, I already run that.
Now, let's go to
confirm a booking without payment.
So, I run this my engines. The first one
is
Abis. Come on, man. I Yeah, because I
Yeah, it confirmed the booking without
payment because it doesn't have any
rules and the promise is super basic.
And the other one is
Let's open this and is
booking blocked. Payment must be
verified before the confirmation. Thank
you. So, it's okay.
Now, let's run the other one. Test
second scenario.
What is the question?
Booking hotel access guest limit. So,
the question is I Yeah, I have more than
So,
here
the hotel Abis successful booking for
Yeah, because the promise is basic and I
don't put in any rule there. And for the
other one, it seemed that the Grand
Hotel has maximum capacity of 10 guests
per booking. Additional booking must be
made at last 1 day in advance. I don't
remember the day. Probably This is
something that they give them.
And to validate booking is both engines
execute all rules pass.
Because they Yeah, it's only a
validation for booking. So, book hotel
for blah blah blah. All rules passes.
It seemed that the booking is still
needs to make.
I don't I didn't remember the question.
So, booking
is made provide I Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, I get it.
And
Okay.
Now, run all the thing this question.
Confirming without payment, booking save
max.
And what happened here? This is all the
scenarios that we just run. So, this is
awesome thing to compare the results.
So, Bali booking king secure five
guesses, allowance, correct, wrong.
50,
blocked, wrong, correct.
Confirm, so there we have here the
comparison between the two ends.
So, what we have what we have here is
same model, same tools, same prompt.
And the different that outcome because
the rules are in Python knowing the
prompt.
This pattern of enforcing rules in code
before the tools run
is also what Amazon Aion core policies
service that we have
does at the structural level. So, the
same concept but managed for you in
production. And you only have to create
the rules. So, the hooks are all or
nothing.
They block everything or approve.
But sometimes you want the agent to
adjust and keep going. No and stop and
leave the user waiting.
That is what I will show you in the
next.
Run time guardians, run time is still
is still don't block. This is the next
one.
Hooks blocks unconditionally.
The agent is stop and the user has to
retry.
For a hard constraint, that is exactly
what you want. But sometimes the rule is
soft.
Maybe room fits for four guests, but a
group of six could go book two different
rooms.
Or a flight is full, but there is
ability on the next one.
You do
No, you don't want to block everything.
Probably, you want the agent to find a
option and complete the task.
That is a steering.
Here, we have the hook that fires and
the task failed.
And with agent control, it steered the
models and the task complete.
The other different here is operational.
Because with the hooks, it's uh changing
a rule means changing code and redeploy
the whole harness, whole the engine. And
with the agent control, which is the
name of the open source library that we
are going to use here,
rules are registered on a local server
via API.
You open the agent without touching the
agent code because the agent picks them
up immediately.
Let me show you that here in the code.
Yeah, this is the notebook.
In this demo, we only need a extra
packet.
The
agent control is the key.
So, the agent control is the one that
helps us to create a steering. And here,
we are using the setup control.
This is a a little application, a little
app that I create with the local server
and the steering rules. Here, we have
the local server. We have the control.
They [snorts] are the steering rules.
First, we have the
the steer master guest.
A steer, you know, guy. So, guy agent to
reduce a guest count
when exceeding maximum of 10.
And he's going to steer.
And we have some control that deny. For
example, deny no payment. Block blocking
confirmation without PR payment.
And
here, well, this is to
to create the
um
the service. The service. And let's go
to the
uh
notebook. So, I'm ready.
Um
Let me
go here. Yeah. So, I need the
environment.
So, this is
the agent.
Um
I'm going to have a error here. Wait.
Wait. Wait. I'm going to use bedroom.
Wait. Wait.
No, then let me comment this one because
this going to give me a error.
And let's run this.
Yeah, so we have the hooks as we did the
demo.
So, we have book any company Lisbon and
we have some prompts.
You are a hotel booking assistant. When
booking, first describe what you will
book in blah blah. And this is the
prompt for my agent. Where is my agent?
Agent control. This is for the
Well, this is on some helper. And this
is my hook that you already know because
we create this. So, we have the system
prompt.
And we have the hooks. So, let's test
this agent with the
uh book any company Lisbon for 60
guests. And if you remember, this only
can book for uh
less than 10 guesses.
And of course, he's blocking.
Now, let's go to the AIN control new
agent.
Here we have
two key importances or two key imports
that are important for the AIN control
SDK. So, we have the AIN control plugin
that captures AIN events and sends them
to the AIN control server. And we have
the AIN control student handle that
listen for a student decision for the
server and delivers them back to the
model.
Together here
they are
what connects a student to the AIN
control student logic.
So,
let's go this with this.
So, the student agent
is going to a river room for any company
list board 50 guests. Let's see what
it's doing. Yeah, I have to set for
booking for a stay in the company list
board for 50 guests
for May.
So, it's the reservation have been split
into two rooms. So, it took that it in
self.
You know?
One room for one and other room for five
and that's it.
So, use hook for hard constraints.
AIN control for software [snorts] rule.
Now, we have
five technique or running locally. But,
how do you take this to production
without maintaining service, without
building infrastructure?
Let me show you how.
Everything that I just built here in the
previous demos runs locally.
For the production version, Amazon
Bedrock Bedrock
Amazon Bedrock AIN core give you the run
time.
A gateway,
a short term and a long term memory, a
cloud watch observability, build in no
servers to manage.
Here the architecture,
the strands engine runs inside the run
time. And you know, you inside the run
time, you can put every framework that
you want, not only run a strands.
The gateway rules tools calls to the
lambda function automatically as a
tools. And the steering rules from the
previous demo live in the DynamoDB.
So, you change them there and they are
live on the next call.
And
you don't need to re-deploy anything.
And you want to use Neo4j, of course,
you can use Neo4j Aura DB, that is a
external graph database, which also has
a free tier. And the code is in the repo
here.
Is in the repo.
And
you will need AWS credentials if you're
using Amazon Bella Betray in core.
And in the resource link, there is some
credits. I hope that you can find it
because I always try to to give away
some credit for AWS so you can deploy
everything for free.
And uh if you are new here in AWS, I
have a repository that you can use to
deploy everything over this architecture
uh using a notebook, too. But, if you
are familiar with CDK, cloud developer
kit, you can do it that as well to
deploy everything at once.
Uh both options are in the repository,
of course. And you can go deeper in
Agent Core with all the documentation
that I left there.
So, please don't stop at the demo and
try going to production with Amazon
better agent car.
So, let me bring it all back.
Tokens
waste on every request.
You can fix it with semantic tool
selection.
And confident answer it's never
computed.
Possibly it's possible because you are
asking how many. So, you can use graph
rack and query the data. Don't sample
it.
Sometimes we have fabric case success
confirmation. You can use multi-agent
validation and second pass catch it.
And rules the models
uh quite a little skip it.
You can use
uh neurosymbolic guardians to enforce in
the code. Don't trust in the prompt.
And for the hard blocks that I stopped
the user, you can use runtime SDR,
self-correct, and finish.
Each demo that I just showed you is in
the in the repository as a notebook and
an application as well.
Start with the demo one
and then go to the demo five. And if you
want,
deploy it in the productions.
So, have you tried any of these in your
own hands?
Thank you to join me in this session and
happy building.